Kim Kardashian reveals she nearly
suffered a miscarriage while she was
pregnant with her daughter north that
was so hysterical I thought my life was
over the 36 year old reality star
appeared on the Keeping Up with the
Kardashians 10-year anniversary special
on Sunday night where she shared plenty
of memories good and bad from the past
decade among them a heartbreaking story
about why she initially hid her
pregnancy I was so scared and I was
having so much pain and I mean at one
point I thought I had a miscarriage flew
all the way home on Thanksgiving and the
doctor told me I you know there's no
heartbeat you had a miscarriage and then
I went in that morning and he's like
there's a heartbeat you didn't have a
miscarriage and I'm like oh my god this
is a sign I mean it was like such an
emotional Thanksgiving Kim also revealed
her pregnancy was a surprise to her and
then boyfriend Kanye West Chloe and I
had gone to a fertility doctor and they
said they think it would be really hard
for me and so I was about to freeze my
eggs and then I randomly got pregnant
Kim and Kanye are now married and
parents two four-year-old north and
almost two-year old Saints their kids
occasionally appear on the reality show
at first we were like our kids will
never be on and I said that no my
daughter is not gonna be on and she's
just like always around me and she's so
cute so I'm like I just want people to
see a little bit
[Music]
you